The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
DAVID THORBURN: Good
afternoon, people.
We begin this afternoon our--
if I'm right about this,
I think I am, as
the syllabus shows--
that this is the last
American film we'll
be looking at in the term.
So we're sort of finishing
of the Central American
phase of our course
with tonight's film,
Robert Altman's
McCabe & Mrs. Miller.
And I want to use this
afternoon's lecture
to contextualize that moment of
the early '70s-- the late '60s
and early '70s-- in
American film history.
And to try to draw out
some of the implications
of the astonishing
transformation that overtook
American film in this period.
We've been talking about
this topic in different ways
all semester.
So by now I think the narrative
that I've been implicitly
following in the
course should already
be overt for all of you.
The film we're going
to see tonight,
Robert Altman's
McCabe & Mrs. Miller,
can be understood as are
particularly clear example
of the kind of transformation
and even subversion that
becomes a dominant note
of American movie making
in the 1970s.
And part of the
lecture today will
be devoted to
speculating about why
that transformation, why those
forms of subversion, occurred.
And of course, if you've been
paying attention in the course,
you know the answer
already and it's
the answer that's already
embedded in the lecture
outline.
A new form of what I've been
calling consensus narrative
emerges really decisively by
the middle and end of the 1960s
and into the 1970s.
It's a period that takes time
but, essentially, television
supplants the movies
as the central story
system of the society.
Not that movies become
trivial or unimportant,
but they begin to occupy
a new niche in the media
ecology of the country.
And I'll return to this matter
briefly in a few moments.
But let me begin by
clarifying something
about the importance of the
presence in our syllabus
of McCabe & Mrs. Miller
and more generally,
the prominence we've
given in our course
to the genre of
the Western film.
So I ask you to remember the
sorts of things we were saying
about genre forms generally.
About the aptness--
even one one might
think of as the
economic necessity
genre forms for a
system that is based
on the principle
of mass production.
And I also want
to suggest to you
that the particular
forms of genre story,
the particular
kind of story that
is told in a particular society
and certainly the ones that
are told in the generic
forms that are chosen
by American society, are going
to very powerfully reflect
aspects of the culture.
And we made a special
emphasis on the importance
in our previous classes of
two particular genres that
emerge with great
decisiveness in the sound era.
Both identified by some scholars
as America's most distinctive
contribution to world cinema.
One form was the
screwball comedy
and the elaborations on
comedy that developed
through the '30s and 1940s.
And the second form, the
second distinctive American
contribution to film--
has some scholars
have sais-- is the Western.
And we've talked a bit about
the nature of the Western
and how the Western
as a form is rooted
in the assumptions
and preoccupations
of American culture.
How it grows out of an
historical actuality--
the period roughly
from 1860 to 1890--
when the Civil War occurred,
when the range wars occurred,
when the when the great
gold discoveries were made
at the California
Gold Rush, the laying
of the transcontinental
railroad.
All of these
historical realities
that become mythic elements
in the founding story that
becomes the epic account
of American identity.
The epic account of
America's founding.
And I've suggested that the
creation of that mythology,
expressed so powerfully
and complexly often--
and disturbingly too because
there's a racism, as we've
said and imperialism
implicit in certain aspects
of the Western mythology--
that fundamental energy
of the genre, as
we've suggested,
is not only deeply rooted
in American culture,
and grows out of the particular
individualistic preoccupations
of American culture as
we suggested last time.
But also, then becomes a
particularly dramatic instance
of what we might say the
movies as a whole have
been in American society.
Or were in American society,
until the advent of television.
And that is, each genre,
and then the Western genre
especially, can be
understood as kind
of a small inversion
of the larger processes
that operates in this
consensus system.
And if you recall
the kinds of things
we were suggesting last
week about the evolution
of the Western, what we were
confronting in a certain sense
was the way in which this
astonishingly protean
shift-changing mythology
can be altered depending
on the preoccupations of
the society that wants
to mobilize the mythology.
Another way of putting
this is to say,
the mythology, like the larger
culture, is never fixed.
It's always in process, right.
So that when one Western
appears, a kind of conversation
is going on with all
previous Westerns.
And maybe with other forms
of discourse as well,
about the central preoccupations
that are part of the Western.
I just want to remind you of
the sort of historical scheme
that I sketched in last
time about the Western,
so you can recognize the point
at which McCabe & Mrs. Miller
sort of fits our picture.
Remember that I
suggested in some degree
that when the Western as a form
emerges after the '30s, when
it's mainly are sort of novelty
item, which are singing cowboys
in it and that sort
of thing-- When
the classic Western emerges
in 1939 with John Ford's
film-- what's the
name of the film--
Stagecoach, the first film
that Ford filmed in Monument
Valley-- when the age of
the so-called classical age
of the Western
begins in the 1940s,
I suggested in that lecture that
the Western's of that period
had a kind of
imperial dimension.
That those were the Westerns
that most decisively and fully
celebrated the white settlers
idea of the manifest destiny
of the American experiment.
Which was translated of course
into exterminate the Indians.
The Indians are
sort of in the way.
The Westward expansion
of the United States
was, in many ways, clearly
an imperial and even
a racist project.
But in the period of the
1940s, the disturbing elements
of the mythology were
suppressed or ignored,
even though they were implicit.
Why would that have been.
Well one reason was America
itself was at war in the 1940s.
And the Western was a
particularly appropriate.
It was not the only
vehicle, but it
was one of the vehicles
in which imperial ideas
of American destiny
and American identity
would be articulated
or dramatized.
And I suggested in the
period of the 1950s,
this Western form begin
to complicate itself,
that it became less imperial.
And that there are
many Western films
of the 1950s that
actually reflect
many of the domestic
concerns of that era.
The generation gap, the
discontent of young people
growing up into a society that
seem to have no work for them--
this is the early 1950s.
And as the decade
goes on and leads
into the 1960s, an increasing
awareness of racial turmoil
in the United
States-- so Westerns
begin to be partly about
juvenile delinquency,
or about social problems.
Always filtered, of course,
through the historical lens
of the Western.
And I suggested to you that
the great John Ford classic
Western that we saw last
week, The Searchers,
had already in the
late '50s began
to incorporate certain kinds
of subversive questions.
So the '50s is a
time when the Western
begins to show social problems.
There's a kind of
inward turning,
in which the psychological
problems of characters
become important in a new way.
And then in the '60s, this
questioning of the genre
proceeds and expands
even more fully.
And as we suggested, there are
a series of films of Westerns
in the '60s that, even
more substantially
than The Searchers, begin
to sort of raise doubts
about some of the most
fundamental questions
of the Western.
And of course, as
the decade wears on,
there are increasing
encouragements or incitements
from the larger culture--
from the social history
of the larger culture-- to
make the Western genre begin
to question itself.
And what are those
things that begin
to happen as the '60s wears on.
They were embedded
in the '50s but they
become much more serious.
The first is racial
turmoil, right.
The Civil Rights Movement
becomes more and more
militant through the 1960s.
And there is real conflict
in the society emerging
very powerfully.
And that racial turmoil becomes
more and more militant, more
and more polarizing
as the decade goes on.
But what's the other great
terrible fact of the 1960s,
that explains why American
society was so divided.
And so uncertain of itself.
The Vietnam War
of course, right.
By the end of the
decade, America's
deeply immersed in Vietnam.
The college-aged generation
is alienated from its elders.
There are demonstrations on
campuses in 1967, '68, right.
And then in 1968, two really
horrific assassinations
occurred to help mark the 1960s
as a decisively disturbed time
in American history.
Who are the two
great figures who die
and were assassinated in 1968.
One is Martin Luther King,
the great hero of a peaceful,
Ghandi-like Civil Rights
Movement is assassinated.
And that gives it
even stronger impetus
to the more militant
arguments for civil rights
that unlike Doctor
King's position,
did not so it really
embrace nonviolence.
So the combination
of the Vietnam War
and the civil rights
movement combining together
created a tremendous
turmoil in American society.
And there are many
film historians
who would say that the totally
subversive genre films,
the anti-genre films that
emerge in the 1970s-- of which
the most decisive
example in our course
is McCabe & Mrs. Miller, so
it completes our argument.
There are many who would say
that a sufficient explanation
for the subversion of the genre,
for the fact that the Westerns
of the '70s-- that some of
the Westerns of the '70s
and beyond-- in
some sense, could
be identified as anti Western.
So hostile are they--
so hostile are they
to the basic assumptions
of their ancestors,
so much that they
turn the heroic values
of their ancestors
on their head.
And you'll and you'll see a
wonderfully decisive example
of this in tonight's film.
There's some social
and film historians
who would say, well,
the difficulties
in the outer society-- the
war, the Civil Rights Movement,
the polarization
of the culture is
sufficient to explain why
these genres, and especially
this centrally American
genre the Western,
would suddenly sort
of turn on itself
and attack what it had
previously celebrated.
The notions of
individualistic achievement.
Notions of violent masculinity.
One of the best books on the Old
West and on the Western film,
has the wonderful title
Regeneration through Violence.
And it does describe
what the classic Western
seems to believe.
It's actually a scary idea.
You might think about how often
this notion has been translated
into sort of foreign policy
behavior by the United States.
Again, reinforcing the
importance of these
mythologies.
But the social
history of the country
is not really sufficient fully,
to explain why the movies would
become so subversive.
And what's the answer.
It's implied up here
in number three, right.
It has to do with the
new consensus medium.
So let me try to make these
arguments in a slightly more
systematic way.
And first, by talking
more concretely
about the ways in
which the movies
were different in the 1970s.
Wherever we look at central
elements of the movies,
we can see a profound change in
atmosphere and tone and feel.
The first, if we think about the
sort of characteristic actors
or acting styles of the
period, and especially
the characteristic
stars and contrast them
to the great stars
of the studio era,
we can get a feel
for how much more
subversive, problematic,
ironic, anti-heroic, this
new period in American film is.
But there are many, many
people who would actually
say that this moment in American
film is actually one of the--
and I think I
might say this-- is
a moment of great
artistic achievement.
Whatever we would say about the
early '70s and the whole decade
of the '70s, we could call
it a moment or a period
of profound transition.
A great artistic achievement.
But also, an achievement
gotten at a profound cost.
A fundamental,
irreversible shift
in the relation of American
movies to their audience, OK.
So that's the basic idea.
But what did this shift look
like, what did it feel like.
Well, I've suggested that it's
grungier, more ironic, deeply
anti-heroic.
And one way I can
capture this is
by taking a scene from
one of the characteristic,
really defining actors of the
1970s, of what we might call
the post-consensus era, the
post-Hollywood era, Jack
Nicholson.
I want to show you
what is, in some sense,
his signature scene.
And people who
haven't seen Five Easy
Pieces, where this
fragment comes from,
know about this scene.
What I want to propose to
you as you look at this scene
is think about Jack Nicholson's
behavior in the scene.
And ask yourself, is it possible
to imagine one of the classic,
much more dignified heroes--
male protagonists== movie
stars-- from an earlier era
behaving in the same way.
Could we imagine John
Wayne behaving this way.
Or could we imagine
Jimmy Stewart
behaving this way or
Henry Fonda behaving.
And of course the answer--
I'm sure as you'll recognize--
is no.
Here's the scene then,
from Five Easy Pieces.
Some people would call it Jack
Nicholson's signature moment.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-I'd like a, uh, plain
omelette, no potatoes,
tomatoes instead, cup of
coffee, and wheat toast.
-No substitutions.
-What do you mean?
You don't have any tomatoes?
-Only what's on the menu.
You can have a number
two-- a plain omelette.
It comes with cottage
fries and rolls.
-Yeah I know what it comes with.
But it's not what I want.
-Well I'll come back when
you make up your mind.
-Wait a minute.
I have made up my mind.
I'd like a plain omelet,
no potatoes on the plate,
a cup of coffee, and a
side order of wheat toast.
-I'm sorry we don't have
any side orders of toast.
I'll give you an English
muffin or a coffee roll.
-What do you mean you don't
make side orders of toast?
You make sandwiches, don't you?
-Would you like to
talk to the manager?
-Hey Mac--
-Shut up.
You've got bread and
toaster of some kind?
-I don't make the rules.
-OK I'll make it as
easy for you as I can.
I'd like an omelet,
plain, and a chicken salad
sandwich on wheat toast.
No mayonnaise, no
butter, no lettuce.
And a cup of coffee.
-A number two, chicken
sal san, hold the butter,
the lettuce, the mayonnaise.
And a cup of coffee.
Anything else?
-Yeah, now all you have
to do is hold the chicken,
bring me the toast, give me
a check for the chicken salad
sandwich, and you
haven't broken any rules.
-You want me to hold
the chicken, huh?
-I want you to hold
it between your knees.
-You see that sign, sir?
Yes you'll all have to leave.
I'm not taking any more of
your smartness and sarcasm?
-Do you see this sign?
-[INAUDIBLE]
[END PLAYBACK]
DAVID THORBURN: Now,
you've seen Nicholson
in far more frenetic moments
in, let's say the Batman movie,
right.
But the essence of the
Nicholson character, he's
actually calmer and nicer
there than he normally is.
His persona has not
been fully established
at this early stage
in his career.
But you can feel
the energy there.
And the hostility
to-- I think we're
supposed to be on Nicholson's
side in that film--
but when he knocks that
stuff off the table.
He's doing something
that we would never
imagine a classic Hollywood
hero to have done.
And I don't want
to put too great
of an emphasis on
a single scene,
but if you think about
Nicholson's incarnations
after that movie, you'll
understand how decisively
and fully a new kind of actor
has emerged in the 1970s.
And you might talk about some
of the other actors-- you
can do the other
sheet there, Greg--
that emerge in this period.
Warren Beatty.
Elliot Gould.
Dustin Hoffman.
Robert De Niro.
Fewer female stars
emerge in this period.
But they're important.
some of them did begin their
careers around this time.
And even the actresses
standing in the same sort
of ironizing and anti-heroic
relation to their ancestors
as the male actors.
We might think about
Julie Christie,
who is the co-star of tonight's
film in McCabe & Mrs. Miller.
Or Jane Fonda.
Or the actress Faye Dunaway,
who does such a brilliant job
in the characteristic
early '70s film, Chinatown.
And each of these
performers, has,
as I suggested,
a sort of grungy,
ironized, non-heroic
relationship
to the iconic figures
of the Hollywood past.
And something of
the same thing is
true about the
kinds of directors
and the kinds of films that
emerged in this period,
as well.
It's the period in
which some directors who
then became dominant figures
over the next 30 years, Martin
Scorsese, Roman Polanski,
Alan J. Pakula, Francis Ford
Coppola, Sam Peckinpah, Altman
himself, Stanley Kubrick.
All of these really
distinctive, auteurist directors
emerge decisively
in this period.
And again, the
films that they make
have a kind of
personal stamp that
would not have been
possible in the studio era.
And of course, what I've
left out of the equation
in talking about
the transformation
of American movies,
is the reminder
that it was in the
period from 1950
through the late
'60s or early '70s,
that the apparatus of
the old Hollywood system
began to break down.
Movies continued to be
made, but the old studios
by the end of the '60s
all really dissolved.
The studios no longer
held contracts for dozens,
if not hundreds, of actors
and armies of technicians
and so forth.
The mass production
system that had
been characteristic of Hollywood
for most of the 20th century
had broken down by
the end of the '70s.
And what movie is
really had become,
essentially, were deals.
You've got a bankable
star to agree to a script.
You get the screenwriter
to agree to do the work.
You go to the money man and
you say, I've got Nicholson
and I've got this screenwriter,
how about if we go ahead
on the movie.
Very different from the days in
which the studio bosses would
sit down and say,
we have to produce
x number of films this year.
Let's decide how many
Westerns, how many comedies
we want to make.
Let's decide how we want to
use Barbara Stanwyck this year,
that sort of thing.
That game is all over.
So that from the
economic circumstances
and the physical ways
in which movies are made
have undergone a
transformation, as well.
Every movie becomes a
kind of major product.
And even though the studio
names survive beyond the 1960s,
they're just names.
They're just labels now.
They actually no
longer represent
what they had in the studio era.
Not only a particular
number of films
that each studio would
pump out each year,
but holdings in land
and major movie studios
with all the supporting
material and personnel
necessary to run a
systematic operation
for the mass
production of movies.
That game is over really
by the time the '70s began.
And if you actually look
at the physical appearance
of the actors of
this period, you
could see that they
look less grand.
They look less large.
They literally are
often not as tall.
Dustin Hoffman's a shrimp,
is even shorter than I am.
When he acts with
some female stars,
they have to put him
on a box so it doesn't
look like he's too small.
They don't photograph
the box, of course.
And there's something,
not exactly wimpish,
but ironic or outlawish,
an unwholesomeness
over a nervousness or a
sense of explosive anger--
the Nicholson character is a
wonderful instance of that--
might emerge.
These qualities, the instability
of the idea of the hero
is part of what is
emerging in these periods.
And I have another clip I
want to show you that I think
and capture another
part of this.
It will also
illustrate the new sort
of grungy type hero
and movie star who
emerges in this period.
But it will also tell
you something else
about the way in which
these transformations
and subversions were expressed
in films, themselves.
And this is a clip from the end
of another Robert Altman movie,
made roughly around
the same time.
It's also a genre film.
And like McCabe & Mrs. Miller,
it's a kind of anti-genre film.
It uses the trappings
of a traditional genre,
but he turns those
trappings askew
in ways that make the audience
nervous, in ways that depart,
from not just the standard
expectations of the genre,
but even the moral assumptions
that are made by the genre.
In this case, the
moral assumption
that is at most decisively
undercut, as you'll see,
has to do with the moral
rectitude of the hero, himself.
And this expresses
itself all the way
through many of these stories
and many of these films,
but it often expresses itself
with particular clarity
in the endings of films.
So watch for the kind of
actor that Elliot Gould
is, because he's
the star, he plays
the detective in this sequence.
I want you to look
now, at the final,
really sort of the
climactic sequence--
the dramatic ending-- of
an Altman detective film.
A remake of a film by the
same title, based on a novel
by the same title, going
back into the '20s.
It's a film entitled
The Long Goodbye.
And it stars Raymond Chandler's
most famous private eye figure.
This private eye figure had
been played in the past,
by a series of really, sort
of tough guy, Hollywood leads.
And in Altman's version
of The Long Goodbye,
I think Robert Mitchum, in
fact, a very hulk, bulky kind
of tough, studly kind of actor
had played the role at least
once, previously.
In Altman's version of the film,
Elliot Gould plays the roll.
And Eliot Gould is a
kind of-- as some of you
know if you've seen
his acting-- is
an actor for the modern
age in some ways.
He talks to himself a lot.
He always a kind of
anti-heroic demeanor.
So, remember we've said also
that the endings of genre forms
are often very conventionalized.
Think about the endings
of situation comedy,
as an example.
Or the way in which, at the end
of certain forms of melodrama,
you expect certain
forms of reassurance.
That things will work out,
or have worked out, right.
One of the fundamental
functions of the happy ending
of most genre forms in the
classic age of Hollywood
was precisely to return us
to that form of reassurance.
All right, so here is the
ending of a detective film
called The Long Goodbye,
starring Elliot Gould.
And perhaps the
only thing I need
to do to introduce the
scene, is to simply say
that the detective's quest
has led him, finally,
at the end of the film, to
sort of solve the mystery.
And he's found the
man who has committed
the horrendous crimes he's been
investigating through the film.
And the man turns out to
have been a friend of his,
someone he has known.
And in fact, someone who
had taken advantage of him.
And here's the very
end of the film.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-How you doing, Terry?
-Marlowe?
I guess if anybody's going to
track me down, it'd be you.
Want a drink or something?
-No, I don't want no drink.
-You get a kick out of
that medicine I sent ya?
-Yeah, I got a big
kick out of it.
So you murdered your
wife, huh Terry?
-Well I killed her, but
you can't call it murder.
Wade told her about Eileen
and me, she started screaming.
She was gonna tell the cops.
She knew I was carrying
money for Augustine.
She was gonna turn me in.
I hit her.
I didn't try to
kill her, I hit her.
I didn't mean it!
-I saw the photographs, boy.
You bashed your face in.
She didn't give me any choice!
-You didn't have
much choice, huh?
So you used me.
-The hell, that's what friends
are for, I was in a jam.
Come on, have a drink.
I had a dead wife, $350,000
that doesn't belong to me,
I had to get out.
It's as simple as that.
-Simple as that, huh?
-Goddamn simple.
Cops have me legally dead.
Augustine's got his money, he's
not looking for me anymore.
I got a girl that loves me.
I got more money than Sylvia
and Augustine put together.
What the hell, nobody cares.
-Yeah, nobody cares but me.
-Well, that's you Marlowe.
You'll never learn,
you're a born loser.
-Yeah, I even lost my cat.
[END PLAYBACK]
DAVID THORBURN: Pretty shocking.
The hero of the movie--
the protagonist-- the guy
we identify with
all the way through
commits cold-blooded murder.
He's a vigilante-- commits
cold blooded murder
at the end of the film.
And that is the end of the film.
He gets away with it.
So there is a kind
of justice done
at the end of the film
in a kind of narrow way,
because the murderer
is caught and punished.
And incidentally,
this violates what
happens in the original novel.
It violates what happens
in the first film
version of the novel.
But think what happens
to genre forms,
not only when the hero
or the protagonist
becomes grungy ironic and
anti-heroic in his behavior
and demeanor.
And then when the story itself
begins to undermine the deepest
assumptions about
heroism and righteous
behavior that seem to justify
or undergird these endings.
But in a way, one
could say it's a happy
ending if one has a very
austere notion of justice.
An almost inhuman
notion of justice.
But what about this
protagonist who
does his own vigilante justice.
And when the film
first appeared--
it's impossible to
exaggerate the effect
this shocking and had.
One reason it's so
shocking of course,
is that the generic
expectations run so totally
in the opposite direction-- that
the most cold blooded murder
in the film should be the
character with whom you've
identified all the way through.
Who is supposed to
be solving the crime
and bringing evil to
justice should turn out
to be evil himself in such
a shocking and brutal way
undermines some of the most
up the basic assumptions
you make about
the kind of safety
that the genre of
the detective story
seems to afford to its viewer.
And this is not an
isolated instance,
as you'll see in tonight's film.
Altman does almost exactly the
same thing with the Western
that he does in The Long
Goodbye to the detective story.
I'll return tonight to
say a little bit more
about the particular ways
in which McCabe & Mrs.
Miller embodies this notion
I've been suggesting to you.
Embodies the anti-generic
or subversive principles
of the kinds of
movies that begin
to emerge at the end of
the '60s and in the 1970s.
Well I've already talked to
you about the social history
of the '60s and '70s.
And I don't want
to repeat myself,
but there were some things that
I left out in my quick account
earlier.
So let's return
briefly to remember
the sequence of presidents.
Because of course, the sequence
of presidents-- Kennedy,
who was assassinated in
the early '60s, right.
Already, the social fabric
in the United States
was frayed to the
point of breaking
by the end of the '60s.
Those of us who lived
through it will always
remember it as an
astonishingly polarized time.
And in the progression from
Kennedy to Johnson to Nixon,
there is a social
history in which
that change in the society
is of course, implied.
And of course, it concludes in
a way, with the terrible event
of the Watergate scandal--
the Watergate investigations--
in which for the first
time in our history,
a sitting president resigned.
And so you can see that the
outward social-- and of course,
the Watergate
scandal raised doubts
about the probity and
decency of the highest
officers of our government.
And while that might
not seem so surprising
in the age of-- I have to
avoid offending some of you--
in our current situation,
where it isn't that
difficult to doubt what we're
told by our government leaders,
it's important to
recognize that-- not
that this was a new
experience for Americans,
governments always
lie-- but there really
was a sense of disillusionment
with the fundamental structures
of the society
that was emerging.
Because of the Civil
Rights Movement.
Then because of the well
because of the war in Vietnam.
And then also, as
a kind of icing
on the cake in a certain sense,
a kind of terrible addition
to this weakening the
country, but strengthening
this sense of polarization
and disturbances, if nothing
can be trusted.
As if our structures
are falling apart
or are endangered in some way
was the fact the president,
in effect resigned, rather
than face impeachment.
Because of his behavior
in the Watergate business.
So the highest
levels of government
and the fundamental structures
of government were in play.
And it would obviously, in such
a time, it's not inappropriate.
You would expect the central
story forms of a culture
to reflect some disturbance.
But why is it not
sufficient simply
to urge this social
history argument?
To explain what
happened to movies?
The simplest answer
is, if you look
at what was on television
at the same time,
you can certainly see television
becoming more complex.
In fact, the late
'60s and early '70s
are a transforming moment
for television, as well.
Partly because that's the moment
when television consciously
realized that it has a more
central place in the society
than the movies did.
It had, for awhile,
already achieved this.
But no one on either side of
the divide fully recognized it.
But by the late
'60s and early '70s,
American television
now knows itself
to be the central medium
of consensus narrative.
The society recognizes
that the changes occur.
I don't mean that
legislation is passed,
I mean this understanding slowly
dawns over a period of time,
right.
And there was a great
sense among filmmakers
of liberation and freedom.
And they're not
wrong about that.
I mean, one might
argue that the '70s
is the greatest decade of all in
the history of American movies.
So many remarkable films
were made in that time.
And surely, one of
the reasons for it
was film was liberated
from the necessity
to embrace what
we're ultimately,
although very
generous principles,
they were still in the end,
conservative principles.
About how a story in a consensus
medium can be told, right.
But the reason that the
social history argument
is insufficient for explaining
the way movies changed,
is that if you
look at television
you could state a
story system that's
telling stories that are more
complex, and more ironized,
and do raise certain
kinds of questions
about the social and
political order that
might be thought to be
disturbing, and even
potentially subversive.
But on television,
the center holds.
On television, the
endings remain happy,
or at least reassuring, mostly.
On television, some of the very
same genre forms, especially
detective and cop shows,
are all over the place.
The fables of law and order.
Fables of injustice.
And the stories that are
being told on television
do not have the
subversive, completely,
anti-generic energies that
we're being told on television.
Why not?
And again, my
answer is the movies
have been supplanted
by television.
That consensus role is now
being played by television.
And one, quite, I think,
truly dramatic way
in which we can recognize
this development is
to talk about the differences
between the movie version
and the television version of
another Robert Altman text.
One of his distinctive films
of the 1970s, the movie, MASH.
How many of you have
seen Altman's MASH?
Only two, three, not very many.
But it's a significant film.
Not as remarkable, I
think, in its full shape
as the film you're
going to see tonight.
But a very, very
remarkable film.
How many of you have seem
the television show, MASH.
A much larger number.
But still, for an
American environment,
a very small number.
Especially because the show was
on for, in its original run,
for something-- I
forgot-- like 11 years.
It's one of the longest
running shows American history.
And then of course,
it was in re-run
for more than a decade
in virtually every market
in the United States.
So there's hardly anyone
over the age of probably 15
or 20 in the United
States who hasn't
seen many episodes of MASH.
So it's somewhat surprising
that only a minority of you
have seen it.
But we can take the difference
between the television version
of that story and
the movie version
as a kind of emblem
for this transformation
that I've been talking about.
And you don't have to seen
either of the films fully
to see what I have in mind.
Elliot Gould, the character
that you saw just a moment
to go in the clip
from The Long Goodbye,
is one of the central
doctors in the movie.
And the other doctor,
the partner doctor,
characters that are played by
Alan Alda and a comrade, who
changes over the
course of the full run
of the show in the series.
Elliot Gould plays that
character in the movies
and his partner-- also
varies in the film--
but his most decisive
partner is Donald Sutherland.
And Donald Sutherland
is another of these sort
of ironic, anti-heroic actors.
They're often actors
whose diction is odd.
They mumble and they
swallow their words.
They're sometimes
literally harder
to hear than their
elocutionarily superior--
bad adverb-- than their
better spoken ancestors
in the classic age of Hollywood.
The movie MASH came
out in 1970 and it
was a kind of disguised
Vietnam fable,
it was officially
based on a novel
describing a MASH
unit-- a medical unit--
in the Korean War.
And the movie dealt with the
Korean War too, ostensibly.
But it was clearly a
metaphor for the current war
that we were in.
And the doctors, especially
the two central characters
played by Elliot Gould
and Donald Sutherland,
are unbelievably
subversive figures.
They take their energies
more from the counterculture
than they do from
any other source.
They have no respect
for authority at all.
They engage in forms of
subversive monkey business, all
the way through the
Altman version of MASH.
When the movie is translated
a year or two later,
still while the Vietnam War is
on-- onto American television
in 1972, I guess--
And the series are oddly
quite a lot different.
It does still mobilize certain
anti-war sentiments, of course.
But, the television
program-- which
I think in an artistic
sense is probably
over the long run
of its series better
than the movie for
all kinds of reasons,
partly because the characters
evolve and change over time
in the series in a way that
could not in the movie--
but the most decisive
thing about it
is that the television series
retains some of the qualities
that we associate with
an anti-genre form.
There are subversive
implications in it, for sure.
But the center holds in
the television version.
Why?
When I say the center
holds, what I mean
is that the remains in the
film are respect for the larger
structures of authority
and order in a society,
however antic and subversive
the doctors might behave
in any particular instance.
The literal behavior of the
characters is often less grungy
and doesn't work with
pornography on the television
show as it does in the movie.
I don't mean that the
movie is pornographic,
but it's much more overt
about sexual matters
than the more than the
television series is.
And one of the best ways
one can see the contrast
is to contrast an actor
like Alan Alda with an actor
like Elliot Gould.
There's something dark and
grungy and self-reflective,
self-aware about
Elliot Gould that one
doesn't feel about Alda.
Alda is much easier in his
skin than Elliot Gould.
One feels about Elliot
Gould as about many
of the actors that emerges--
dominant stars in the '70s
and beyond-- is that
they're afflicted
by a kind of cosmic anxiety.
That they're anxious figures,
that they're figures of damage,
in some way.
Warren Beatty is such
an actor in many ways.
He's the star of tonight's
film, McCabe & Mrs. Miller.
There's a particularly
wonderful film of the 1970s
that I also want to mention
to you after I complete
my discourse about MASH.
So these two versions of MASH
then, sort of dramatize for us,
not that television becomes--
especially by 1970-- simply
a reactionary medium
that just repeats
what the ruling class in the
United States wants to say.
It's a much more complicated
medium than that.
But it is a consensus medium.
It understands that
it operates according
to certain unwritten rules
that the society, as a whole,
has accepted.
And one of those rules is
that in a consensus medium,
you can mobilize all kinds
doubts, and dubieties,
and ironic perspectives
on the larger culture
are on the central
values of the culture.
But you can't repudiate
them completely.
You can't let people come out
of a consensus medium thinking
that the society
is totally corrupt.
That there's no
hope for the world.
Consensus systems
won't allow that.
They have a comes a kind
of aesthetic and political
conservatism built into them.
And the movie MASH
shows how free it
is of those consensus values.
The television show
MASH, on the contrary,
demonstrates how much pressure
a particular genre may
receive and still remain, in
some sense, a consensus form.
And it seems to me,
there are many arguments
to be made for
the idea that MASH
is one of the most distinctive
artistic achievements
of American television.
That it represents
the culmination,
in some sense of
series traditions
that go back almost 30 years
by the time MASH appears.
But what gives it its
real authority and power
is that incorporates
into itself a subject
matter that, before
the mid '60s,
anyway had never been
on television before.
So it's not that the television
that appears in the late '60s
early '70s is
trivial or foolish,
it's just that it is
constrained by these consensus
principles that no longer
constrain the American movie.
And when we look
at tonight's film,
you'll see very decisive
examples of this.
And I'm excited about how
clearly McCabe & Mrs. Miller
will crystallize the
kinds of things I've been
saying to you this afternoon.
Now I also want to mention
this other example.
A film I meant to
mention earlier
when I was going through these
notions about the way in which
we have different
kinds of directors,
different kinds of actors,
different kinds of endings,
right.
Which means that the
style of the movies
is often different, as well.
The visual texture
of the film is--
they favor jump cuts
and discontinuity tricks
much more than the classic
Hollywood movie does.
And the film I wanted
to tell you about
is a film-- I meant
to mention earlier
and I'll conclude
today's lecture
with sort of another example,
like the examples I've
given so far-- in
which what we get
is it a profoundly
subversive film.
Whose presence would have been
impossible five years earlier,
or 10 years earlier, when
the movies were still
performing their consensus
function in American society.
The film I'm thinking about as
a film by the director, Alan J
Pakula, some people
call him Alan Peculiar,
called The Parallax View.
Any of you seen
The Parallax View?
It's one of the great films
of this early '70s period.
And it's a conspiracy
fantasy film.
Warren Beatty plays the central
character in the film, a drunk.
And fact that he's a drunkard
and radically imperfect person,
is also characteristic
of the kinds
of heroes-- a protagonist--
that we begin to see in the '70s
and beyond.
Radically imperfect
protagonists begin
to become much more the
norm in American movies
after the Hollywood
system has declined.
Well in this film,
Warren Beatty plays
a recovered
alcoholic journalist,
who has been fired from a
series of important jobs
and is now working
for a minor newspaper
in Seattle, Washington.
His name is Frady.
F-R-A-I-D-Y, I think,
or maybe it's F-R-A-D-Y,
but it's supposed
to echo afraid.
He's like a fraidy cat.
you're supposed to sort of
partly feel in the film.
And with the help of
a newspaper editor
he works for, he
stumbles upon what
turns out to be a vast
political conspiracy.
He's actually present in
the beginning of the film,
at what looks like
a random killing
of a political candidate.
Begins to investigate,
he discovers in fact,
that there was
probably conspiracy.
The candidate was assassinated.
And then he goes
undercover and he engages
in a long investigation.
The shape of the film, and
the energies of the film,
are very like dozens of films
we've seen earlier, especially
during the Hollywood era.
In which a lone hero,
discovering terrible facts that
are dangerous to his
community or his society,
shows the courage
and the fortitude
and the end resilience,
and the focus,
to follow through
and solve the mystery
and then save the world.
In the most elaborate versions
of this fantasy, what's
at stake is the fate of the
world or the fate of a society.
In smaller versions, it might
be something somewhat less.
And that's what
it turns out here.
He penetrates into
this conspiracy
and there are allusions
and references
that make you-- especially
at the end of the film--
associate the conspiracy with
the Kennedy assassination.
There is, in the film then,
a kind of ongoing process
in which the full nature of the
conspiracy begins to emerge.
And in fact, it is
an unbelievable.
If you actually saw
the world in that way
you probably couldn't even
get a job in the White House.
I'm sorry.
But said it's really an
unbelievably conspiratorial
film, in which it turns out
that there are a sort of network
of corporate controllers
who are sort of, in effect,
taking over the government
of the United States.
And they have unbelievable
power nobody knows-- but anyway.
This detective has
finally uncovered the plot
and watch him do it.
And as the film comes
to its conclusion, what
do we expect will happen?
What's the normal
expectation in such a film?
That his revelations
will save the day, right.
Well in the very final
sequences of this film,
we see what looks like a kind
of revelation scene, in which
our character, Frady,
is in a convention hall
where they're about to hold
the political nominating
convention in fact.
It's very resonant because
the conspirators are trying
to control that space as well.
And essentially, he
starts chasing a bad guy,
being chased by a bad
guy, without going
into any detail-- I'll spoil the
film for you a little in a way,
I must-- guess what happens.
Our hero is killed at the end.
And the film ends with the
idea that the conspiracy
is enforced.
That there's been no change.
So, it would have been
a disturbing film,
even if it had ended with
the requisite happy ending
and a reassuring ending.
And in and how many films does
the great hero, the character
you've been following
all the way through,
who's supposed to be one
in which you've invested
all your sympathy and respect.
In how many films does this
guy get blown away at the end.
But it's a mark
of how subversive,
how morally turbulent, and
politically and morally engaged
movies had become by the
early '70s, that's such an
was possible.
So, The Parallax View is another
kind of anti-genre in a way.
It's like a spy film--
in some ways it's
like one of those Hitchcock
romantic thrillers, in which
Cary Grant and a
beautiful woman travel
through beautiful locales and
finally, even though they look
as if they're in great
danger, win the day
and are able to marry at the
end then also incidentally,
have saved the United
States government.
The film fits that
kind of category,
but it explodes all
of our expectations
about the characters and about
the atmosphere of such films.
And in that sense,
The Parallax View,
like McCabe & Mrs. Miller,
like Altman's film MASH,
like his film Nashville,
like the films
of Martin Scorsese that appear--
Mean Streets, his first film
and maybe his greatest
film appears in this period
as well-- have given you a much
grungier, more disturbed, more
damaged, more hopeless view of
urban violence than any film
before it had done.
Again, mobilizing the
genres of the gangster
film and the urban crime film.
But mobilizing it in a way that
leaves the viewer unsettled
and disturbed.
So the '70s is an
astonishing, remarkable moment
in the history of American film.
It's remarkable, not
only because films
became more courageous
and more dangerous
in the thematic and moral
sense, but also because it
was an era in which that
happened in consequence
of the fact that the
movies had surrendered
their central place
in American society
to this new medium
of television.
I'll talk about some
of these matters
tonight in a much more
concrete way by looking closely
at McCabe & Mrs. Miller.